and when you look back or think back you
recognize that man do you know what was
going on in Charlie Sheen's head back
then I recognise him by name not by
character it's a it's it's it's very um
you know what the shame shivers are sore
so but yeah imagine what they are yeah
we all can get a sense of what you know
like the night before he driving home
like oh my god I did that yeah there
there there there shame shivers for
watching whatever incarnation of who I
thought I was in those moments I I just
think I got so tired of saying somebody
else's words and and being told how to
say them that I I decided in perhaps
inappropriate or radically appropriate
moments like the ABC interview this and
that too to write my own script you know
and then and then things caught fire and
the world stood up took notice and and I
was just sort of along for the ride you
know because it became a global story
when yeah I mean it went supernova yeah
really yeah yeah when again looking back
when you were diagnosed as HIV positive
what that was that the thing that pushed
you over the edge was not just part of
no that was much later okay so it was
like from one winning moment to the next
no people think that the tiger blood
thing was me sort of you know issuing a
hint or something or some some some
measure of I don't know what but but
know that that that was just what I call
a triple C of a cosmic collision course
yeah you know it's not really had
nothing to do with it but but but there
was something radically liberating and
and and and something very freeing about
being able to to to come out you know to
say look here's what I'm in dealing with
because from the outside the answer to
he and that did seem like a pivotal
moment that your life can change right
and then outside if you don't mind my
mentioning you said it then when they
came back to me oh no they'd say you
look like the rain yeah it's bad
so if you you could watch this on
youtube and try to get an interview with
Matt Lauer yeah in the states where he
came forward and said that you were HIV
vulture and and I was just saying
there's an amazing moment where it cut
back to you and you rarely see this
moment of someone who's the weight is
gone you right you've told your secret
and the world didn't end
ethereal II that that was true
internally and how I felt emotionally
but what I did before we went to the
commercial break I caught a glimpse of
myself on the monitor and I was really
dark and so during the break I told Gabe
to come back out to my makeup artist and
make my eyes
I can carry a tune I was like you sure I
know somebody I'm gonna